i infrequently agree with lindsey graham
on a number of issues judges immigration
and so forth
but he said something the other day on
brother sean hannity's program which has
said to be controversial
and he's taking a lot of incoming from
the putin wing of the republican party
from the
putin pravda related american press
and of course from the american marxist
and the democrat party and what is it
he suggested in so many words that it
would be nice if a hero would step up
who's in putin's inner circle and take
them out
and that created controversy
i'm not exactly sure why that created
controversy
and so lindsey graham for that has taken
more heat than vladimir putin has for
actually using assassination and murder
in order to stay in power
in order to gain power and in order to
try and take out the president of
ukraine
here we have a piece in the daily mail
ukrainian president vladimir zielinski
has survived three assassination
attempts in the past week
plots were filed by double agents within
what is the old
kgb and now the new fsb
um turns out that the wagner group
which i'll get to in a second and i've
talked to about on radio
uh is behind two of the attempts and
then chechnyan hit squad is behind one
of the attempts obviously they were all
sent there by putin there's said to be
400 members of this wagner group which
is based in africa which is a mercenary
secretive hit group
a quasi-military arm of putin's army
in
kiev that were placed there in advance
of this war
and they were foiled by subversive
anti-war members within russia's federal
security service this according to the
daily mail
the successor to the kgb who alerted
ukrainian officials
ukrainian secretary of national security
and defense confirmed the attempts
one group that reportedly tried to kill
him was the shadowy wagner group which
has 400 members located in kiev they
infiltrated
ukraine
with a 24 name kill list so they have a
hit list of assassinations
that they are supposed to undertake on
behalf of putin
the other group was chechnyand which are
elite soldiers as part of the russian
national guard and are known for their
brutal tactics
and of course zielinski is the number
one target so putin
came to power and has held power through
assassination
now how do we know that because it's
very very well documented in fact our
country has warned the united nations
and the united nations is well aware
that russia has a kill list of
ukrainians to be detained or killed
should they capture any of these
individuals including zielinski his
cabinet members of parliament
journalists on and on and on
and in fact homeland security newswire
yes i do my research
uh has put together way back in august
of 2020 the list is longer now putin's
victims a long list of
people who've been mis disappeared or
murdered
uh who've dared to question putin
we have uh his intelligence operatives
have killed many domestic critics
opposition politicians journalists
investigative reporters academicians and
artists and more than a dozen russian
defectors like alexandre letaneko in
london in 2006
russian intelligence operatives have
also killed russians who were not
outspoken critics of the regime leading
russian experts to speculate
that putin has adopted a milder version
of stalin's tactics of random killings
in order to instill a generalized sense
of fear and insecurity in the russian
elite and they provide a list again this
list is a year and a half old of 16
politicians opposition politicians
business people who wouldn't go along
with putin's
ideology
and also
such as it is and wouldn't give him a
piece of their action
he's killed diplomats he's killed 122
journalists
whose deaths were rey who were arranged
by operatives of putin and his regime
and it goes through the list
who they are
why he targeted them
and how they were murdered seems pretty
serious to me
i'll just give you a few examples boris
nemtimsav 2015 in the 1990s he was one
of the leaders the post-soviet russians
young reformers
he became deputy prime minister and was
for a while seen as possible
presidential material but it was putin
who succeeded yeltsin in 2000 nemtsov
initially supported the choice but he
grew increasingly critical and was
pushed to the margins of russian
political life in february 2015
military involvement in ukraine nebuchad
was shot four times in the back by an
unknown assailant within view of the
kremlin putin took personal control in
the investigation
into the murder
but the killer remains at large
boris brzezrovsky 2013 is self-styled
tycoon was a member of yeltsin's inner
circle in the late 1990s he was
instrumental putin's rise to power
including a media campaign that smeared
boris nemtsov who was upcoming within
with putin to succeed yeltsin
but but beretsovsky soon fell out with
putin and left russia for a comfortable
self-exile in the uk
the distance from russia emboldened him
and he declared that he would devote his
and his considerable wealth to bring
down putin he was also leading a
campaign to investigate the november
2006 killing in london by the
radioactive substance polenium in 2010
of alexander litvinenko a former kgb
agent who became a leading critic of
putin in 2018 a british intelligence
investigation established that two
agents of the
fsb the kgb successor group killed
ludwinko by slipping the radioactive
material on his tee you remember this
anyway berensovsky was found dead inside
a locked bathroom at his home in london
a noose around his neck in what was at
first deemed a suicide but the coroner's
office could not determine the cause of
death and it goes on and on and on well
mark
why do we care about any of this we'll
get to that in a minute
then we have this document from the
carnegie endowment for international
peace no doubt a neocon operation you
know no doubt about that
the federal contractors are behind this
no doubt about that putin's not so
secret mercenaries patronage geopolitics
and the wagner group by nathaniel
reynolds this is the wagner group that
up until now you probably have never
heard of before
just a few points moscow first deployed
wagner in ukraine at a time when the
kremlin needed to fight a covert ward
high casualties from the russian public
and mitigate the international
repercussions of a gross violation of a
neighbor's sovereignty
the use of mercenaries or proxies is a
tactic with deep roots in russian
history most notably during the cold war
by using so-called volunteers and other
groups of the irregulars in ukraine
moscow nominally reduced the number of
active duty personnel and concealed
their presence at least initially
the recruitment of these groups happened
quickly in 2014
and the kremlin turned to private and
state actors to finance and organize the
effort what else
russ's covert war in ukraine sparked
western alarm over moscow's use of
mercenaries and other deniable
instruments of subversion this is back
in 2014
which are often lumped together as part
of a so-called hybrid warfare
concern remains that moscow might
secretly deploy wagner or similar forces
elsewhere in the post-soviet space to
start another covert war destabilize a
country through sabotage and subversion
by using mercenaries as it did in
ukraine moscow would hope to sow
confusion around its involvement keep
the west divided and stay below obvious
thresholds for robust response
mark why are you getting into all these
things
we know that putin is a killer we know
he's assassin
we know his interests in uh the
countries that surround russia we know
he wants to rebuild the old soviet union
actually the russian empire wrote a long
essay about it
over the summer what does that have to
do with us everything
we have a putin wing in the republican
party with a putin wing in the media we
have a putin corps in the democrat party
and in academia
and you'll hear them and you'll see them
and they talk about how the united
states may escalate war
against putin
now it's they lavarov and other lap dogs
of putin who have talked about nuclear
war it is putin himself who's talked
about nuclear war we're not
and they rarely ever criticize putin or
they do it in a passing way in order to
say something
about the united states and how stupid
we are and how stupid our generals are
and so forth now there may be that
i mean biden is the so-called
commander-in-chief
he is a disgrace in a disaster he
actually has the russians negotiating
with the iranians when they nuclear deal
with us
what kind of a fool does that i will
never know
he puts more sanctions on the american
oil industry and no sanctions on the
russian oil industry as i speak what
kind of a fool does that when we can use
oil to debilitate the russian economy
the putin economy and war machine rather
than debilitate you mr and mrs america
we do have a damn fool in the white
house there's no question about that and
we should be muscling up our military
for any possibilities and we're not
despite spending trillions in trillions
of massive debt we are not muscling up
the united states military
russia china iran the access of evil the
real access of evil now that exists
but why does this matter because ladies
and gentlemen i personally am sick and
tired of hearing the excuses for putin
and the attacks on the united states
that we somehow are going to escalate
something we have been incredibly
passive
in the face of what putin is doing
diplomacy
diplomacy
look who the diplomats are look at the
secretary of state he's pathetic
look at the national security adviser
he's pathetic we've never had such a
pathetic team in modern american history
up against true vile genocidal maniacs
xi the regime in tehran and yes
the fascist putin who's busy running
around and calling the jewish leader
president
of ukraine a nazi think about that
the bad guys the evil guys are the
russians they're not the ukrainians
they're not the americans
they're not the nato forces
but what does bother me
is the ukrainians need weapons to defend
themselves they were promised mig-29s
and their pilots can fight in mig-29s
that's what they use all of a sudden
they were pulled back
i don't favor sending american infantry
into ukraine does anybody i don't think
even lindsey graham does
i don't favor a no-fly zone with
american air force jets and so forth
but can we at least give these freedom
fighters the right to defend themselves
they're now being brutalized they're
being slaughtered they're being shot in
the streets their women are being raped
there's torture taking place
what does this have to do with the
united states
do you think putin is going to be happy
with ukraine any more than he was happy
with crimea any more than he was happy
with georgia he's told us what he wants
to do
you think he's building hypersonic
missiles to attack kiev
he's building hypersonic missiles to get
around our defense systems
the way china's building their navy and
their hypersonic missiles you think
they're doing that to attack taiwan
do you think the iranians are building
intercontinental ballistic missiles to
hit tel aviv they don't need
intercontinental missiles to hit tel
aviv for which they want to put warheads
on by the time this administration is
done in washington
the iranians will have nuclear missiles
china will have conquered taiwan
and russia may well be marching into
other countries who's to stop them
and by the way i would remind you
taiwan's not part of nato does that mean
we don't help defend them israel's not
part of nato does that mean we don't
help defend them what about south korea
if they're attacked do we not do
anything about that
where is the line for the appeasers for
the sellouts for the neocon artists
who are out there preaching peace
but provoking war
you know these genocidal maniacs when
they see weakness as they did in our
withdrawal from afghanistan which was an
absolute horrific disaster where 9 000
american citizens still are behind enemy
lines where 13 brave americans were
slaughtered for no reason
you know what when the enemy sees
weakness the enemy strikes
so they see weakness in the oval office
they see weakness around the oval office
they see weakness much weakness in our
media
and they see weakness period
period we should be arming up the
ukrainians with whatever they need
that's number one we should turn on our
oil and natural gas spigots like never
before drive the russia military machine
into the ground and stop their troops
cold number two we should cut off all
negotiations with iran immediately let
alone having russia has the point to
negotiate that's why biden will not put
sanctions on their oil because he
supposedly needs the russians to
negotiate our deal with the iranians
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else